we're here to take 16. we didn't take
the week off because i was sick last
week we took the week off because there
was nothing [ __ ] happening
you know what we're going to come in
here and talk and bring burn a [ __ ]
guest and [ __ ] it we just took the week
off we're refreshed we hope you had the
same i'm sorry if we left you on the
[ __ ] hook
i got a lot of emails i answered last
night people like what the [ __ ] joey are
you okay
nah it was just that listen man
we've been doing this straight for a
long [ __ ] time and uh i'm taking some
time off for company next two weeks also
nothing staying at the house with the
family and enjoying this we're moving
offices so shit's [ __ ] happening
what's up dawg i had a great last couple
weeks it's uh i don't remember
and not that
my life compared to a lot of people who
work nine to five is pretty
relaxed
but i don't think we've taken time off
ever i don't remember like the last time
like two years ago when i went home to
boston in the winter i don't remember
it's just that uh you know i went away
in november i mean it just got to the
point where you need a break it was
between the stand-up you know i changed
my schedule this week this year a lot
i'm not going out as much
you know because i want to pay more
attention to you guys we're moving
offices next week
same backdrop we're just gonna have a
little office a tv screen still [ __ ]
we're still gonna be bad [ __ ]
we're just moving to an office closer to
the house this was the first office i
wanted a year ago three years yeah more
than a year ago four years ago a friend
of mine had an office over there and it
was just convenient place you had didn't
we weren't in a hallway so we could
spark up a [ __ ] number and we can
make things at home for you and that's
it man so that's what we're doing
everyone needs like there's something
like sometimes when i talk to my parents
because i try to talk to them four or
five times a week there's only so many
things you can talk about and so many
times you can tell the same stories
so it's nice like i i was just sitting
at home
and i was like oh i haven't thought
about this story in a while i haven't i
haven't said this so i'm sure i'm sure
for you it's nice to just not have to
talk as much well you know what i was
focusing i couldn't wait for the end of
the year to come
i cannot wait guys [ __ ] in november
i cannot wait for new year's eve so i
could just take some time off
it just it i i knew it i knew i just
wanted i could not [ __ ] wait and the
more i tried to slow down the busier it
got
little things kept popping up i still
got the podcast i still got my family i
still got all these responsibilities
you know the worst thing to do is to
that people do
that i did for years and then used to
get pissed off was
i became a regular person and you guys
are going to go what are you talking
about let me tell you what i'm talking
about i became
i bought into this [ __ ]
i bought into the mindset
that people slowed down
after thanksgiving
and i played into it my first three
years here and then i started working
i never really liked dropping the ball
during the holidays it's the [ __ ]
holidays
once christmas day is over with my mind
i'm about to kill somebody like i'm
ready to go to work i'm ready to [ __ ]
start doing stand up i'm ready to start
acting whatever the [ __ ] is gonna happen
let's make it happen like i'm one of
those guys like i get [ __ ] anxious
like i'm ready is it because like
when like if i if you take a couple
weeks off of working out when you start
working out again it's gonna take it's
gonna suck and it's gonna take you a
while to get going again so is it
because now like like you've been saying
for the past few days this week it's not
right not like everyone's gonna be doing
stuff in my world this is dead like this
isn't dead for me i still want to rock
and roll but i could tell that everybody
else is dead like it's today people are
just telling stories and what they got
and what they ate for christmas and how
the flight was a lot of people ain't
flying back till today
the flights go straight now till
wednesday maybe thursday if you're smart
you stay home till thursday or friday if
you're getting yeah if you can why you
have you know i'm not talking about i'm
talking about generalities here how
people like to travel i would never
[ __ ] travel over the holidays lee
every [ __ ] year you see people stuck
and they make sure they show them to you
on the news and those cots in chicago
and [ __ ] see that like young girl crying
oh i felt so bad she was just sobbing
hey listen man this time of the year you
you're throwing a 50
[ __ ] dice uh 50 whatever the [ __ ] it
is 50 50 chance even if it's not like
even if like you're flying from here
where there's no snow the plane could be
coming from chicago or somewhere else
it's it's scary like that's for
comedians
it's amazing how
nonchalant you guys are about flying
even though
you could get your big money week could
be cancelled
at the drop of a hat if there's a whole
bunch of snow okay but the week starts
on monday so you already have a you
already know what's going on you already
know what's going on on monday if you're
a smart person you're looking at the
national weather on monday and they're
telling you there's a snowstorm in
[ __ ] chicago hitting monday dropping
24 inches you ain't going to new york
city on friday i ain't no [ __ ]
weatherman but if something's in chicago
on [ __ ] wednesday it's going to be
alive and kicking in new york on friday
right if it's no 24 inches in chicago
guess what we're going to get 9 to 12 in
[ __ ] new york you don't need to be a
[ __ ] uh thermologist whatever they
[ __ ] mean
you know they all call themselves like
johnny storm or you know mikey thunder
you ain't dick you're making a high
profit whatever the [ __ ] that is an
educated guess the ones in l.a are scary
they're terry but they're terrible
listen yeah my wife wake up is that
coming down i think i go no it's sunny
and [ __ ] 60. she couldn't believe it
this morning yeah they've been staying
it's gonna come down sunday night you
know this guy scared the [ __ ] out of
these [ __ ] white people now they're
doing 40 instead of 60.
that's all this is
so if that's what i look at i look at
the weather remember that the situation
we had in boston and i kept saying you
get the [ __ ] out of there yeah i know on
monday you know if you know anything
about weather patterns you know if they
got hit now colorado's different but if
it's headed out
iowa and east you're dead and you see
what direction it's going let's say it
throws off a little bit if it throws off
a little bit from iowa boston's getting
killed
that's right in the way of boston so it
doesn't take so you're in contact with
the club hey man what's going on well
now some club owners are [ __ ] morons
some club owners
will take the chance and guess what
happens lee
yeah so you get
12 inches on wednesday night
or thursday you cancel the show thursday
but friday ain't nobody going down
even if you shovel the roads right so
you understand you see a big snowstorm
coming you know your area as a
businessman you've lived there you know
listen let's call it let's reschedule
this [ __ ] bring a magician in
this weekend and handle our losses
we still got the tickets people's money
they're not going nowhere they're going
to come see joey we'll just reschedule
them real quick we'll just what's your
schedule look like joey
right you know for me to go to buffalo
for them to get two feet of snow for me
to do one show on saturday night or two
it's happened to tom segura last year he
got somewhere and ended up doing like
one and a half shows jesus do you ever
get
bummed out about the weather like my dad
was in nightclubs for a majority of my
childhood and if it rained i just
i knew he was going to be he wasn't
angry at me but he would be angry like
it would ruin his night because he knew
at 3 p.m
that no one was going to come to his
parties well anybody who's a success
a successful bar running those
except for [ __ ] a tornado
or a 12-inch snowstorm and even then
people will come out
if you got a real bar listen you're not
gonna get the 190 you expected but
you're to get 60 alcoholics down
yeah we only got 60 alcoholics out there
everybody knows when it's going to snow
and they're going to go let me go get a
couple let me go get a few packs of
cigarettes and a bottle of bring home i
might as well stop at joe and mary's and
get a [ __ ] cocktail
yeah you know and on the east coast it's
different out here like you said it was
going to rain and the whole city was
going to shut down because of some rain
some [ __ ] rain but i'm talking about
uh
somebody who's going to go out
do you think when i was doing blow
and i wanted to get my dick sucked and i
was getting an eight ball and i had
money in my pocket that a full of snow
scared me
i'd get those [ __ ] snowshoes and i'd
walk all the way up to john mary's or
when i lived in colorado i'd walk up to
the stone bridge wherever the [ __ ] i was
i walked up
yeah if you're doing what you're doing
if you're real you're out the weather
don't stop nobody but [ __ ] rain rain
don't stop a coke fiend or somebody's
gonna do some pills and go to a bar and
have three cocktails rain don't stop
nobody from getting a piece of [ __ ]
right well you you had a thing for a few
years that you were going to like really
snowy locations during like the winter
months
is it because you figured like those
people
will be able to handle and they'll come
out either way or it was like when i
first heard of it and you did a couple
years in a row i was like so i was very
surprised i go to columbus and i go to
buffalo in january usually this yeah
and then minnesota the last couple years
too minnesota oh one year i went to
minnesota i just fee i like the cold
weather
i like it so i want to feel it i want to
feel what they're feeling i want to make
them come out in their [ __ ] weather i
like that [ __ ] buffalo is a great city
man and they don't give a [ __ ] about
weather they had 11 feet of snow last
year they're still going they don't give
a [ __ ] about weather if you're funny and
they want to party they'll come down
that's what i'm saying
so the weather
affects it to a degree you know in the
winter time but i've seen
people get stuck in cities people shut
down you know and you can't do nothing
for two or three days that i wouldn't
mind if i got weed or i got a way to get
weed and somebody delivers to the hotel
i'm good i'll just sit there for two
days and write jokes you're doing me a
[ __ ] favor
i'll do laundry i'll do my own laundry
downstairs i'll get a whole new set of
clothes i'll wash my workout clothes
and i'll keep [ __ ] working out until
the plane leaves
that's something that i actually wanted
to work on this year
is not getting as upset when there's
like nothing like when there's no
nothing i can do to control it like i'm
a big
i i'll beep or get mad at someone
driving really slow in front of me or
if like my flight's canceled i'd get
upset before
and there's nothing i've gotten better
at it but there's literally nothing you
can do to make sure that i had a bad
thing i had mother's day
and when my flight was at some point i
get home until nine o'clock at night 10
30 and i didn't get home
and i got a little hot but i knew
i got hot when they didn't tell us the
information that's what gets me hot when
american airlines puts you on a flight
and you sit there you have the
connecting flight from you go to lax to
nashville and then let's oh no you got
lax chicago and you collected chicago to
go to nashville you board the plane in
chicago that taylor gonna defrost the
[ __ ] plane then defrost and they tell
you there's something wrong with
something they got to bring apart get
off the [ __ ] plane that's what pisses
me off oh they're the worst me [ __ ]
hot i'm not not
you know that they delay things are
gonna happen yeah that's why take the
first [ __ ] flight out
because those [ __ ] are never
delayed they'll push him out because
they know
let's at least get one flight out there
to get it there to pick up the people
that are coming back or whatever the
[ __ ] they're going the airlines will
take a shot with that that's what i do
have to give them but i got one delay
last year i really can't complain one or
two delays last year i really can't one
was a ten hour one yeah that was a long
one but i had weed
i had a pen a vapor pen i had an
e-cigarette i had everything covered
so if something i got my ipod which i
lost this last time on the way back from
vegas i got to call southwest again uh
you know
you just travel you just get used to
it's life you just get [ __ ] used to
it you know what i can never get used to
when i first got here i had the worst
thing going on i can never get used to
working on a set
really oh i hated it
basketball i [ __ ] hated it hated it
being on that set that was my first big
time on the set hey how you doing hey
your call tomorrow seven o'clock okay
seven i get there eat some breakfast and
we'll get back to you so what's going on
i don't see my number on the sheet they
give you a sheet with the number of the
scenes they're going to shoot and who's
in the scene you're looking at this at
the sheet going okay i'm number 38.
number 38 is the last scene of the day
oh no and your call is seven in the
morning seven in the morning so what do
you do so you have two options if you
don't have prepared
sometimes they put you in a box bro
sometimes in the big movies you get a
little trailer but you got tv
it's you don't get no reception
you get wk you get like [ __ ]
different channels from europe and [ __ ]
and telemundo you even notice how
telemundo comes through you don't need
an antenna nothing you don't even need a
tv just put your hand up with aluminum
foil and you'll get [ __ ] telemundo
and korean stations around here and
korean station will get through they
[ __ ] play on the radio and [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] telemundo always comes
up anywhere i've been to dalla moon
saying you hit maracas and people
dancing they'll [ __ ] tell a novella
but uh
what was he talking about i don't even
know what i'm talking about like
traveling yeah no i listen no the movies
you [ __ ]
those sets and now the movie sorry and
then i think
the third movie i figured it out
i think by uh american gun
i had it figured out and that's the
first time i i brought a book
and i brought a
i brought a notebook
and i brought a pencil you know yeah and
i wrote a little bit that was the first
time then i figured out people were
bringing ipods
wow i could take a walk and smoke a
joint
and then i figured out people were
bringing dvds like in the longest shot i
had a dvd player
so i just started bringing bruce lee
movies and [ __ ] and we just watched
movies in my trailer with the air
conditioner what was that like so on
some movies you're there for like a day
right if you're there for weeks are you
do you have to be on set every day all
day just in case they need you for
something no you get there and there's
numbers all right so i'm number six on
the longest yard i was number like 11 or
something like that as long as you're
so they have different scenes scene
number 38 doesn't happen you see number
62 doesn't have me scene 11 has me
so i got two scenes till i work now i go
on the set and i see how quick they're
moving
uh they're moving like [ __ ] molasses
so what do you think about 12 o'clock
yeah twelve one o'clock after lunch [ __ ]
i go back to my trailer i roll a joint i
go for a [ __ ] walk i burn that
[ __ ] and i come back and put a
movie on and i sit there so you wouldn't
be nervous about missing like i
i'm the king of nerves about stuff like
that like i would always be
nervous they won't i'm gonna miss it
sometimes they'll switch your number but
where were you i was in the back looking
at a bird
like well hurry up suit up they're
looking for you that's but you know if
they're into a scene and they're in the
beginning of the scene oh you got time
especially if people have to fall or
something the firecrack has to go off or
something
that's they have to turn the cameras
around if you're shooting on a tv show
it's two ways
if you're shooting on a movie maybe they
take it from all angles when i shot i
analyzed that i was on the set from 8 30
to [ __ ] 750
jesus me and anthony lompoglia all day
all day with [ __ ] what's his name
from stripes directing all [ __ ] day
remus ramis oh cool and he was in front
of us they shot us from you it was de
niro so de niro shoots from 12
10 2
3 9
4 8 and 6 o'clock
and you have to do it all those times
all those times i was shocked by that i
went to go see them tape the new the
matthew perry show with my mom we were
there for like four hours and they taped
like
not even the first act of the show yet
and we we just got up and left it was
but it was just too much it was like we
were there for like four hours that [ __ ]
takes time and they got all the money in
the world so if the director wants to
move it's three takes
boom boom boom one for you one for me do
it the way it says on the book
do it the way he wants to do it not do
it your way move on to the next one
let's shoot from this angle let's shoot
from this angle i don't need you in this
shot lee go sit down for five minutes
because i don't see you i'll just have a
stand then me i'm a professional i stand
in i'll wait there and stand there oh so
for like over the shoulders on my
shoulder you can't see
they're not going to see you on this
show go take a walk so with like stars
like de niro or something leave for that
all those shots are never them nah
sometimes they walk away oh i'll get
water i'll stay there sometimes if i'm
not doing what i'm gonna do in my room
let's do it let me all i'm doing is
getting better with de niro i wouldn't
leave i sat like glued next to him yeah
i'm learning i'm learning so why not do
the take keep doing the take keep doing
the take i'm only going to get better
i'm going to get more confidence i might
learn something in the [ __ ] takes
do they always shoot
movies in single camera have there been
any multi-cam movies i was just thinking
about about how that might work well
what are they showing the longest yard
for example when they shoot when i shot
spider-man there was cameras everywhere
oh
the more the bigger the budget let's put
a camera they put cameras everywhere you
know with the longest shot it was the
first time they used that technology
they're using the nfl now with the
camera on the stream oh yeah so there
was some scenes we shot with a camera on
the string
[ __ ] uh you know uh catapults and
cameras and people hanging down and all
at the same time like i guess for the
football game it would make sense yeah
for the football game you have to shoot
it for me because you have to have a
camera on the running back
on who's ever gonna make the tackle on
the quarterback
you have to have cameras on different
people so in editing yeah you can put it
together so you have to have all those
cameras and the stars of the [ __ ]
team the longest yard they they had shot
the same people that shot the other
football movie had shot the longest yard
okay but
i i guess it was slower for some people
so those football scenes
you have to hike and then the guy has to
get the ball and there's a camera there
so you see him running through but you
want to see him from the fan's
perspective and you also want to see him
from the other side it was very hard to
shoot a sports movie it's very hard to
shoot a lot of [ __ ] movies man
it's just hearts and now that i've done
it when i watch movies i know what
they're going through
you know i know what they're going
through when i see a movie getting shot
and i understand
you know i shot law and order svu in
[ __ ] january
you think they gave a [ __ ] it was 92
below zero and the winds were coming off
the hudson and [ __ ] i was down on
canal street so those little winds were
making me [ __ ] and in the video you see
me with a t-shirt on like it's [ __ ]
yesterday
oh yeah like a robe on like it's
yesterday
in between takes you put your jacket on
you warm up they warm up your hands
but when you're right there you're right
there jack that's you talking like
normal you can't go
it's freaking cold you gotta [ __ ] sit
there and go okay this is what's going
on
you know when i when i shot that movie i
also talked to the guy that was in that
boat movie from the guys from boston the
perfect storm okay yeah yeah a guy from
buffalo the quarterback from the other
team
from the mean machine oh yeah the guy
from buffalo whatever his name is and i
got friendly with him and we were
talking about that moving he was telling
me it was four weeks of just underwater
training so before the movie and they
pay you for this
but before the movie starts you got to
go and jump in the ocean and you know
there's sharks and they take that fear
away from you and if you know you got to
say that [ __ ] in the meetings
so what does this entail you know you're
going to be in the water you're going to
be in the ocean you know that right it's
cold there's no heaters
you know some of the scenes they do in
the pool and they throw ink in the water
and looks like the ocean but some of the
scenes you got to jump in for two
seconds when we did the [ __ ] thing
scene
when we all jump in the mud in the
longest shower okay we get there we got
there that morning and it was frozen
nelly was concerned because he had a
tour that week and he didn't want to get
sick it was [ __ ] freezing out
but once [ __ ] started jumping
in though you know they were like joey
you jumping they came up to me like you
don't have to jump in and you don't want
to
i was like what are you [ __ ] kidding
me you're jumping in
all these gorillas are going to jump in
what are they going to think of me if i
don't jump in right and for stuff like
that though could you did you do
multiple takes of that you probably
can't you have to retakes of that how do
you do it you have to take showers and
chances
off we
cut then we all ran off they take they
take your clothes off they dried us down
they had heaters there
we got heated up we put shirts on they
blew out dry our hair again so it took
like four [ __ ] hours to do three
takes jesus they had a smoothing out the
water dry off the patches where people
don't see the [ __ ] thing
is acting really fun is it just soup
because everything i hear about it from
the audition process all the way through
doesn't seem like it'd be fun at all
like but there's a process of acting
just
a great time
it's fun
i think all of this is fun did you you
watched the fights the other night
carlos said something at the end he goes
i love doing this
i could tell
i could tell you love doing it
if you don't love doing something that
much
don't do it if you're doing it for your
dad
don't do it if you're doing it for your
friend don't do it that's what makes
things easy i always start coming from a
stand-up background
doing
acting was always like my
break every 90 days
like it took my mind away from stand up
and i worked on a set for 11 days three
days six days i will cancel three weeks
of work not because of the money
just because i wanted to save of the
moment i like it
a lot of comics don't like it i [ __ ]
love it
i love just dropping this [ __ ] for
[ __ ] four weeks going to new orleans
and working three days on a movie and
even though it's overnight whatever i
don't that don't bother me man
that [ __ ] don't bother me i think it's
fun i think all these aspects for me are
fun but i really enjoy acting but i also
enjoy stand up the problem with stand-up
is it's a business
and the business side of it [ __ ] gets
me depressed even more so than acting
well the the business side of acting you
know what you're getting yourself into
at scale
i'm a lead i'm a [ __ ] union guy so
they pay me scale so i know sometimes if
it's a tv show you get more than scale
because you're doing a guest star
but for the most part you're you're
working for [ __ ] scale which i know
and i have an option whether to do it or
not you're following me everything is
fun until you throw the business aspect
of it at least it is for me when i'm
gonna ask you for money it sucks dick
you know it sucks dick
doing stand up monday through friday
when you're starting off
it's like i i can't describe it
but i could just imagine getting into
photography for the first time or
getting into uh drawing art or just
taking colors and putting them on an
edsel whatever the [ __ ] the sheets
called you know i'm not i'm not a
internet or or you know anything
anything you do for the first time
that's what makes you fall in love with
that now you want to seek more knowledge
about it and [ __ ] hunt it down and
learn from different directors and you
know anything i'm not plumbing
you know there's some people to you and
me plumbing it off like a bunch of pipes
but to some guys their family's been
doing it for [ __ ] eight generations
and this means everything to them when
they weld the pipe when they [ __ ] uh
whatever prep the pipe with the copper
and mildew you know you're [ __ ] you
know like that that's what it is
a job
is something that you do from nine to
five
a [ __ ] something you love you do all
the time it's not work
it's not work for me when i answered 63
emails yesterday it wasn't work for me i
enjoy talking to people about addictions
and
thank you for listening to the podcast
man i'm happy that you're getting
something out of this you know if not i
wouldn't [ __ ] do it
i want to hear what people have to
[ __ ] say to me
you know danielle gant sends me a letter
every [ __ ] week of his family and
trees and pictures and it's all very
interesting to me these are the people
that listen why is somebody this nice
that takes pictures with a [ __ ]
sweater on and [ __ ] even listening to
the junk we got the [ __ ] talk about
but that's what you know you always want
to seek more knowledge when you're i
look at [ __ ] uh
carlos conduit they were talking about
he's taking movement classes and carlos
condit never stopped
never stopped and something like he had
like 500 strikes or something you know
people always go well i'm taking time
what time are you taking what have you
done
what have you [ __ ] done there's no
time off you know
i was talking about how the holidays
taper off how people get lost in the
holidays
and they and i get it i understand for
some people that they taper off during
the holidays i did it for years and then
i realized that
when i was in town i would book [ __ ]
because everybody else was gone
for years
i would hit my biggest jackpots in
december you know i shot an nfl
commercial christmas eve one year i
swear to my [ __ ] daughter i've never
heard of this what happened an nfl promo
i i booked it on the 22nd
and we shot it at 7 00 am the 24th of
december
they must have really wanted that stuff
doesn't really happen around that like
what was it for was it for the playoffs
or
for the playoffs nfl let's go let's do
this [ __ ]
i shot true promos i still see the guy
around town he lives around town he
always goes hey joey how you doing he
shops at sherman oaks that [ __ ] raps
oh okay so i see the guy in there on the
[ __ ] time so it's it's
this is the [ __ ] that happens
when everybody else isn't paying
attention i used to pay attention
i met
nick apollo at an audition
when they were gonna fire artie lang
from the north macdonald show you know
when i went on that december 20th
the year i [ __ ] went all the way to
the end for get shorty the sequel
they told me december 19th
that i didn't get it all these things
happened the movie with uh
with uh ving rhames and and the mother
black guy blade when they were gonna box
undisputed okay that i booked at that
time of the year around here is when
they went to see me at the comedy store
[ __ ] happens but people like oh no i
gotta i gotta go back home for the
holidays my buddy
had the job on [ __ ] training day
which one
he listen to me he had the job on
training they have gone into
into paula's neighborhood and talking to
gang bangers and getting them all in the
movie for 200 hours a day they were
paying him 400 a day
they offered him like a six-week
position he was he was coming home
telling me how he would hear
denzel rehearsing with ethan hawk in the
other room
like he he this was an education of a
lifetime
he came to me after two weeks and he
said i'm going back home for the
holidays and i said what are you gonna
do about that job he goes i just want to
go home for the holidays
and i remember looking at him they were
giving him two thousand dollars a week
and he left the job after he got two
checks because that's all he needed
he didn't care about the outcome most of
the good things that happened happen
when everybody else is [ __ ] doing
something else and you know he just
didn't want that job then because that
sounds like that's the stupidest thing
i've ever heard one year like january
10th
i used to get the breakdowns in those
days
the breakdowns you get them at like four
in the morning somebody gets them and
steals them from an agency and sends
them to you and then they send them to
lee
and that was my career the breakdowns
are where all the roles for movies come
out they let you know what's getting
shot who's looking for what how many
days blah blah blah blah blah so let's
say it would say uh
breaking bad we're looking for a fat
cuban with a mobster look we're looking
for a jewy guy
that's bald and he has to be on the five
foot six you follow me we're looking for
a black dude with a big dick and a one
arm
and you look at that and i'm i'll never
forget sitting here like everybody was
out of town working and i'm like this
year i'm gonna sit here because i would
leave the whole month of january in the
past where would he go uh syracuse miami
improv
south carolina myrtle beach club the
comedy cabana
yeah i would disappear for the month of
january go to all those places and work
and then come back in february for pilot
season
and there's one year boom characters
wanted
extreme looking guys new york city
looking guys
i looked and it was spiderman too
and they said mail headshots to whatever
i looked at the address i had my wife
look it up on the map and she goes
that's an office
i said you know what i ain't doing
nothing today i put that envelope in and
on my head shot with a [ __ ] letter
i look she cast pretty woman
the one who cast spiderman too whatever
her name was
cast pretty woman
so i said i love pretty women you know
enough
something like cretendon go ahead look
it up something pretending who the [ __ ]
do you think you're dealing with
so i uh
i uh
walked to her i went to her office in
beverly hills and i walked up the stairs
and
and i went to get the door
and the door was open and i walked in
the assistant was sitting there
and i [ __ ] gave her the envelope and
she was like what's going on i go no
diane
crittenden who the [ __ ] do you think
you're dealing with doug
i'll never forget that name as long as i
live you understand me she put me in
spider-man [ __ ] two because i went
down and put the envelope in
because i basically did the work you
know
and that's what happens that time of the
year
nobody else is prepared and there i am
with my dick in my hand ready to [ __ ]
go i think that's the most frustrating
part for people trying to get jobs is
that it
very rarely it seems
matters all about like your
qualifications
i think probably close to 60 percent of
it is who's there
like who they know and who's there and
the hustle but that you showed maybe you
showed up at six in the morning if i go
get a job i show up at six
when you pull up i wanna be there at 7
15. that's the guy that gets the job if
it's a construction job he's out there
freezing that's the guy i want he's been
out here at attention saluting the flag
45 [ __ ] minutes everybody else is
getting coffee smoking cigarettes
thinking about their future
i told you this that before the [ __ ]
break i wrote a list of things i wanted
to do yeah i wanted to go to taco bell i
want to go to strip club well i went to
the strip club one night by myself on a
sunday night i went to the store
and i got off the one side i didn't know
where that was i knew it was somewhere
in the [ __ ] valley
i haven't been to a strip club guys and
[ __ ] since eddie bravo was a dj
at the one by the airport and even that
night like i didn't get a lap dancing
and i just went to pick up eddie
one time i went with joe for something
else that was it
but to be in a strip club like a man and
sit there and watch women dance and [ __ ]
so i get off the [ __ ] 170 and there
it is lights and stuff there's a pool
hall next to it i make a u-turn
i go if i gotta park in the back i ain't
gonna go in there if i gotta park in the
front [ __ ] it i'll go in there pull up
to the front boom
there's a parking spot i have no valet
parking none of that [ __ ] i walk in
there the place is dark
all right i walk in there and i see
[ __ ] some people getting private
dances
i walk into the back i look around there
nobody says dick to me people as guys
are sitting there like like fat chicks
at a dance waiting for
waiting for somebody to come and ask
them to dance and just sitting there
like
and i go you know what this is as creepy
as it was the last time i came to a
strip club i'm out of here
i walk out i get in the [ __ ] car and
i look up and there's a girl going like
this hi
hi i'm like oh hi
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and i look at
it and she's like come back come back
and i'm like what she's like come back i
get out of the car and i go what's up
she says oh my god i can't believe
you're in here
she goes like i listen to the podcast
don't show her boyfriend listen to the
[ __ ] podcast
so i start talking to her she's really
[ __ ] nice you know
she's got a great body and stuff and she
goes here's the menu what do you want to
do and i go i don't know i haven't met
those triplets but they they got like a
a 40-minute lap dance or 20-minute lap
dance or something they got a 10-minute
one nude 40 minutes
i got a 20 minute one i said [ __ ] it
give me one for 20 minutes i was okay
for about eight minutes
i had like a nervous breakdown the first
six and then after that i loosened up my
dick got hard you know that's when you
realize you're okay once your dick gets
hot you're fine the first three minutes
it was brutal the first three minutes it
was [ __ ] brutal it was going through
your head what was going through my head
suicide if i had a gun on me i'd shoot
her and then shoot me right there in
north hollywood where the [ __ ] i was i'm
not used to that stuff lee was she
facing you or was it like oh yeah she
was facing me she was gorgeous she was
28 she was rushing she was beautiful
i've never been in every oh it freaked
me the [ __ ] out
and you know what like i got a heart on
i i nut in my pants i [ __ ] sat there
for the last eight minutes while she
rubbed on me like half dead
dizzy
like i was having a diabetic fit and
then once she got off we talked for a
little while and then i went home my
little load in my pants and dried it
with a tissue and [ __ ] watch this the
honeymoon was or some [ __ ] last sunday
night that's what i did doug but i got
it over with now i gotta hit taco bell i
was gonna say can you please tell us the
the people what the next thing on the
list was it was taco bell yeah
my closet
it was all [ __ ] that i [ __ ] hate
doing
and i had like six things on the list
and i did four out of the six
six things that give me [ __ ] anxiety
that's what i put on the list did you do
taco bell not yet
that [ __ ] is mean anxiety when was the
last time you went talk about was it
that [ __ ] bad
i like it when i'm drunk and high but
other than especially here just seems
stupid when i can go get four tacos for
10 bucks
that are like actual tacos it's the only
time i would go
let me ask you something what's up you
and i drive on that [ __ ] road all the
time
have you ever seen that taco bell not
packed
have you ever never never i mean the
lines around the [ __ ] block not lines
around the block i'm exaggerating but
the lines are around the island to the
end of the parkway constantly oh fast
food
fast food is always busy and that's i
don't know why why don't other people
think like you about the tacos how much
of the tacos was a taco i don't get it
here
maybe a dollar maybe it might even be a
dollar here i don't know how much tacos
are there but it's
the only reason i ever went is because
like i was just so tired like after a
day's work i didn't want to get out of
the car
so like i can see that if you're busy
but if you live it'd be it'd be like
going to
in buffalo going to 7-eleven and getting
a buffalo wing it's
like it's a 7-eleven rather than going
and going to anchor bar or something
it's gross i just wanted to get some
[ __ ] over with because i don't do [ __ ]
you know
let me tell you something man oh i'll
eat the [ __ ] out of i'm just saying it's
i feel that's that's the one i feel bad
about that and like
like kfc i haven't been to in years that
one always made me feel like [ __ ]
i make no notes in a notebook
i go to jiu jitsu
i throw kettlebells around i do a
podcast
i hang out with my wife and my kid
that's about all
anything else i i do i'm scared of doing
or something like i talk myself out of
it
and something really interesting
happened last week i saw the [ __ ] 7-5
for the first time
and you want me was struck in my head
about this guy mike dowd and chicky and
walter you know what struck me [ __ ]
i was a little off last week wasn't i
natalie
some days i was so it was because of
this like i'm not super old but i could
tell some days it was because
i felt something when i watched that
[ __ ] thing i felt that
first of all that was me
you know it's uh
and then i've
realized that that wasn't me
that that was still me that i've been
lying to myself for [ __ ] years like
lying about my
who i am like
what happened was lee at some point in
my life i got really [ __ ] scared or
something
like something scared the [ __ ] remember
i was telling you man that my friends
uh
fernie and [ __ ] kanti were all became
bible beaters and yeah my other buddy
like became bible beaters and it was
like they saw something that one day
made them
uh slowed down with the drugs or
whatever the [ __ ] one guy is not really
a [ __ ] bible b he says you know joel
osteen had but i just found out he was
doing blow a year ago so it's all a lie
anyway
but i think like i was [ __ ] out of my
mind like
everybody who saw that they're like mike
has no respect and you know when we saw
the one guy he looked like a cop but
mike was a [ __ ] real deal and the
other guy was like mike was a
perpetrator whatever a perp or whatever
yeah that was the creepiest one when i
heard
mike talk
you know i never signed up for anything
lee
i never signed up for anything in my
life i was a boy scout for three days
i never belonged to nothing you know it
just never fit me i always felt out of
place you know winely
because i i was different in my head not
because i was a comedian or something
because
of the thoughts i would get as a young
man and what i wanted to do you know
when i was 16 i didn't know what i
wanted to do i knew i wasn't going to
get a [ __ ] job
i never had an aspiration of getting a
job
and once i found out you could take [ __ ]
i knew i wasn't getting a [ __ ] job
like i was like i'm not [ __ ] getting
a job
like i'm telling you the truth that's my
friend i'm telling the podcast listen
it's how i [ __ ] felt
you know like
guys i got in trouble for [ __ ]
putting a machine gun to somebody
and taking the coke
like i didn't give a [ __ ] and the only
thing that really stopped me from doing
a crime spree was that i couldn't get
anybody from north bergen that i trusted
because having somebody with you that
you trust is a different [ __ ] story
as a partner yeah now i got locked up in
88 and i came back out
and i still [ __ ] around with drugs and
sold coke and made little moves but when
i went back home in 93 i did a couple
more of those little [ __ ] drug heists
i'm not gonna lie to nobody and tell you
that i didn't and i made really good
money on the second one it got me
started with my comedy career got me an
apartment i got me a little car it paid
off a lot of the debt i had that paid
off and i liked it when mike dowd is
talking about that [ __ ] the net my
netcast was sticking up
what does i know i know what it's like
what about chicky when they're talking
about that first one where they he
called chicky to go get the bag of money
and he was saying like how
your heart just doesn't stop beating you
until like 20 minutes after i am
on a drown i am still hooked on that
junk
like that
was my biggest drill like
when i shoveled snow in snowmass village
to watch some guy's house
that sold coke and he would leave and i
figured out a way to go into his
apartment and just take
a half ounce of coke every day without
him knowing what was going on
and then at night i'd go back there and
buy 40 worth of coke and tell him i was
broke and nothing was going on and
but like i just played this role
of a guy who didn't do blow meanwhile
i'm robbing the guy every [ __ ] day
without even no remorse or not thinking
twice about it do i feel good about this
today not at all i'm not glamorizing
this at all i'm just telling you who the
[ __ ] i really was deep down inside so
when you're watching this documentary
did a part of you ever been like [ __ ] i
should have been a cop that would have
been a great cover no like it worked
great i wasn't a cop no i know you
weren't a cop
i'm a criminal
there was no charade in my life i never
won a charade in my life
i could have been a cop all those guys
that i went to school got hired as cops
early on i had no police record till
later on
that's not who i wanted to be at all i
was not going to
you know embarrass that [ __ ] thing
and do that i didn't like dirty cops
when i was young when they were coming
to my mother's bar or my mom had the
place in the bronx and they were coming
for payoffs for numbers i it's not that
i didn't like them
they just didn't appeal to me i'm not
talking about mike as a cop i'm talking
as mike the mental state of might and my
mental state okay like when he he didn't
know either see oh he didn't know he
became a cop early on and he didn't know
yeah he said he was clean for like two
years he was really he didn't know he
was really a gangster
once he saw it once you see the
opportunity he was all in i mean listen
when you're about to go kidnap a woman
that's what it drives you to
when you're that crazy listen to me bro
i
i had done a lot of weird things uptight
kidnapped villa
kidnap velo kidnapping villa was a
little high for uncle joey uncle joy
wasn't that [ __ ] smart
i wasn't that prepared at that time
that was an unprepared move on my part i
knew it going in
i knew it wasn't going to work going in
but the addiction was making me do
something different
the addiction was always there and it
makes you do something it it helps you a
lot in making
really bad decisions as we all know
that's part of the addiction is
it's crazy and he he spoke about in the
documentary he had a drinking issue and
other things and i was just watching it
and then with with some of the stuff
that he did you wonder like and some of
the stuff maybe that you did if you
weren't an addict would you have done
half the stuff the same way and listen
it could be an addict to the money
yeah get addicted to the money [ __ ] yeah
eight thousand a week that's four
thousand minimum that's just that's
sixteen thousand a month cash no no
eight thousand each a week i think oh
eight thousand each a week i didn't know
if that's what i thought
it's very interesting when i was
watching it i looked at it from a
different perspective i got sad
but in a way i got very happy because i
realized
that i got to this part of comedy not as
a criminal but with a criminal mentality
of sorts like with the with the
twittering in a way and all that [ __ ]
it's for me
it was like everything else you know i
go into a bar i'd see lee i'd ask lee if
you want a bump i'd give them two bumps
and i cut them off eventually you're
gonna come up with 40 to give it to me
right you know you're gonna go where'd
you get that i got another package right
here let's do this and next thing you
know what [ __ ] i got you for 80 dollars
so did you ever
have a relationship with with like the
cops like that a baron did and like
their i had a relationship with two cops
i had a relationship with a cop in
jersey
and i had a great relationship with a
cop in aspen
jesus in boulder i got arrested because
i probably didn't have a relationship
and aspen i didn't get arrested at all
cops only came to my house one time
announcement i had no police contact and
aspen even though i ran a [ __ ]
i'm lying to you i had police contact in
83 before i left that's when they
figured out it was me who was
burglarizing things but they didn't
arrest me they didn't have enough
proof to arrest me now did you ever like
when you say relationships did you ever
have to pay them off or it was just you
were friendly with them i paid them off
with blows sometimes sometimes i gave
them information you know something like
you got to give them something
they keep you out there you got to give
them something you know you're not a
snitch i wasn't right nobody out i would
just know that lee was getting uh dirty
lee [ __ ] me one night on a pound of
coke often i find out that lee holds his
coke at that honda dealership on the
corners he gets his deliveries there on
friday
you know what you need a bust you know
what when you're busting though don't
forget about giving me something off the
top
because they're going to steal something
if they pick up six keys you think six
keys make it to the [ __ ] police
station no four keys make it to the
police station
and then when it's one of the if you
look at the [ __ ] history of new york
as a whole
okay you know it
what kills me about the seven five is
that everybody's going crazy like they
never heard this [ __ ] before for me this
is what i knew about every day
so for everybody else they're like oh my
god you know okay so the coke gets to
the warehouse once they book it into
[ __ ] uh once they book it into
[ __ ] uh processing and it goes into
evidence the cop who booked it goes and
gets four pounds of [ __ ] dust and now
he goes back one night when nobody's
watching he takes two pounds of coke and
puts two because a kilo is two pounds
pretty much it's a couple [ __ ] pounds
it's uh 32 ounces 32.2 ounces of 34.2
something to that effect so it's two
pounds so you go back with two pounds of
cut you take an ounce of coke put it in
there just to sort and passes the test
and that's what these cops are doing
they became all of them became drug
dealers
all of them they would bust you and sell
your drugs back to you cut you're like
what the [ __ ] is this what do you mean
so i would take up two pounds of coke
from lee right come to the car pull you
over lisa yeah boom smack you what do
you got in the [ __ ] trunk
nothing i take out you got a kilo of
coke right
okay i take it with me and you got there
call come in go ahead
yo
joey what's up my brother
hey what's going on nothing how you guys
doing all right mikey dad
yeah we're hanging out here in uh look
on los olas in fort lauderdale right now
me and walter okay everything all right
what's happening with walter you guys
eating dinner down there you eat some
cuban food
well not yet we might have crossed from
a cuban restaurant buffet we'll have
that in the tomorrow but we had to
bounce and do the whole uh lauderdale
trip you know shooters and uh right now
los olas you know it's we've been
driving a lot on the road the last
couple days quite a bit good for you man
how long are you staying down there
uh we're gonna be down here only till
thursday i'm flying back thursday i was
doing i did my uncle a favor he moved
this uh rest of his uh contents from his
home down to florida as he's down there
full-time
and uh he did the jersey to florida for
about eight ten years now he's moving in
full-time so you know gotta do the right
thing for the family so no no hey we
were just sitting here talking about how
the last
week and a half or so uh the 75's been
all over twitter you know it plays on
showtime and people's [ __ ] people
from farmers
you know white america see this [ __ ] and
their jaw drops and it's just a
sensational
story about one of many you know of one
of many that was one of the worst
precincts in the country for a long time
and here you are i mean
you did you you did your [ __ ] time my
dad i mean you got you don't know nobody
nothing you did your time nobody could
[ __ ] judge you you wouldn't believe
that you'll say you're saying that [ __ ]
okay am i on live radio how much how's
this work yeah
you're having software yeah yeah you can
talk
yeah yeah no my thing is i did my time
but you wouldn't believe the haters that
are out there like you know this isn't
america's second chance place of
opportunity we were built on corruption
to begin with you know we all make
mistakes we pay our dues i got people
hating me you should be dead you should
die you can't sir yeah what am i
supposed to know i'm sorry
can i say it wants to be over i gotta
keep going on for the rest of my [ __ ]
life i don't know you know it's amazing
how for years i also avoided
responsibility once you do your time you
learn how to claim responsibility i tell
people that i you know who shot kennedy
i did
just to end the conversation that's how
you start thinking you know the other
night i had an argument with a friend of
mine at dinner as i dropped her off i
went out i got i hugged you and i said
hey it's a bigger man the bigger the
[ __ ] mistake and she goes i know i
love you and that was it i can't that's
it
you know you're not hiding in a [ __ ]
bush hiding that's why i give you all
the credit in the world
there has nobody in the history of this
[ __ ] that i've seen get more
enthusiastic when you're telling the
story about finding [ __ ] money
only i used to get that enthusiastic
listen there's nothing too
sensationalized about the crimes we did
you know
but but the fact is money you know
that's what we got out of bedford we put
our fans on we put our shoes on to go
make money so when you find money you
know you're not thinking about the blood
that was still over and you're thinking
about what i got in my hand right now i
want it i need it i don't need it i know
someone that does i gave a lot of money
away but you know they don't write about
that they write about you know the
condos on the ocean and the [ __ ]
corvettes and all the [ __ ] you know
but you know i don't want to i don't
listen i don't want anybody pat me on
the back for anything i did i just want
to take responsibility for what i did
and the thing that i found is that the
more responsibility i take the better i
feel and you know if you don't like me
for it then i'm sorry but that's what we
do in life you take responsibility you
can't be shy to talk about it because
there's others out there that wish they
could and they can't because they never
came clean
mike died my life
oh my god my life changed once i started
talking about the kid something i was so
embarrassed about
right something i was so embarrassed
about and one day i started singing
about it talking about it and everything
[ __ ] changed my life changed some
people handled it and they went away
they couldn't handle it and they went
away and the people who did handle it
they're still here
you know why because they people that we
meet should judge us for how we treat
them you know and listen listen i'm not
i'm not condoning any criminal conduct
and i don't think you are as well you
know but we still have to live a life
and you know you have to put your arm
around somebody that turns their life
around and goes forward and wonder how
they do it i mean because i didn't know
how to do it i just do it one step at a
time every day it's like almost like an
aaa program you know one step at a time
you know so what's great about the
documentary is that we see the evolution
i could whoever directed it or you as a
storyteller
i could see how
two young guys become cops
you know get shot at blah blah blah blah
blah blah you look around and all sudden
one day you find an envelope you find
another one
and you got in so deep that at one point
you're drinking just to keep yours
[ __ ] sane that's a lot of people
don't understand that at one point
you're doing so many things you got so
many things going on in your [ __ ] day
that the alcohol is the only thing that
makes you focus and puts you to sleep at
night so you have to think about that
[ __ ] because that's when the ugly comes
out once you're home by yourself at
night you had a couple drinks and a
couple
and you're sitting there going are they
gonna [ __ ] come in through the floor
who's gonna know that they have a camera
there you know oh god oh i've been on a
lot of cameras so
i don't know how i didn't catch me back
in 1988 or 89 i just don't get it you
know that's which is why the thing
turned the way it did because i mean if
you ain't going to catch me now
you people suck i mean and i don't mean
to put anybody down i mean i mean i put
my corvette in the lieutenant spot i
mean come on
i was making 33 000 a year and the call
was 36 000. i just lost 1500 in the
casino
and everybody in the police department
knew it i mean it was embarrassing the
way i was like why are you gonna grab me
for christ's sakes rescue me from myself
because i couldn't do it you know but
hey it is what it is you don't know what
is sitting here fooling around with his
twitter and all that [ __ ] right now
i want to put them on but i got to ask
you something else a lot of people also
understand a lot of the people that are
watching this are young
i left new york walt walter when i
uh gotten like i grew up in manhattan
but my mom had the barn jersey the whole
thing but i had a santeria godmother on
148th and broadway
she
everything everything she was the
baddest [ __ ] in the world when i see
you i'll talk to you more about it i
grew up you know i grew up on 148 and on
the corner they sold weed
since i was a kid even if i didn't smoke
weed there was a puerto rican kid and
then he became a cuban kid then he
became a black kid and one day in 85 i
went to see my godmother before i was
leaving for colorado and i went on that
same [ __ ] block
and do you know what mike i could not
find one seed of marijuana
it was crack
oh yeah crack had taken over the city
from 85 to 91 what he's talking about
was just something that you couldn't
imagine yeah those pictures that's not
you know it
it it clean
it
it hit the police department the way it
hit the street i mean you know not not
not to deflect not to take
responsibility just it hit us all by
storm you know and it was like you know
you watch a tornado look into a
neighborhood and when the tornado walks
out you know the neighborhood's
devastating people like wow it's
beautiful day today the sun's out well
that was the same thing like
it hit the city it was amazing how
destructive it was and you know a lot of
people got sucked up in that in the
winds of the tornado they followed the
funnel
you know i left new york from 85 to 91
and i was telling lee when i watched you
on that show the other day i kind of got
sad mike because you want me to tell you
first off mike if i move to new york the
first guy i'm hanging out with every
night is you
and i'll tell you why because what i
don't have out here is the quality you
have
you might have [ __ ] up whatever i'm
out in california where people don't
look in the eye here you are telling me
the truth
and it made me think about
you know this comedy thing i did this as
a by the way mike
right i did this as a by the way
something happened to me when i hit my
31 32 that i got really scared mike i
had done my last drug rip the summer of
93 on 178
right by uh washington up to washington
heights that's when the dominicans were
up there and we followed the car and the
guy ran out of the car it wasn't even we
didn't have to say tie you up what the
guy before the police
over the cops
and
that was it hilarious and that was it i
left away but i gotta tell you what you
did is what i always wanted to do i love
all that [ __ ] i ain't gonna lie to you
say that
you want me to lie to you and tell you i
grew up to be a comic and i wanted to
hang out with these [ __ ] morons that
have no loyalty and nothing i wanted to
grow up with men who had [ __ ] loyalty
and yeah you [ __ ] up a little bit and
you had a good time you laughed you went
to atlantic city you know
the [ __ ] whole thing you ate all you
could eat crab buffet
but
there was something i liked that i
wanted to always be that
but the problem would happen with me i
grew up watching miami vice you know
what i mean it's all about tubbs and and
the other guys
just crockett and how's these guys
in their capizzios or whatever they're
wearing with their whites they like the
white slacks and the nice little
paisley stuff they'll wear and it just
made you know you don't even want to be
that you know something about it this
morning i get up at five i'm writing and
also at six i turn on the news and i see
miami vices on and i turn it on it's the
episode where crockett loses his mind
towards the end when everybody lost
their mind they were all doing blow so
they came up with a subplot that
crockett lost his mind joe santos was in
the episode uh uh the other game the guy
the gay guy el gato
he was in the house
i lost a book contract over that word
el gato oh the you can't say the gay guy
i don't know i got in trouble using the
word [ __ ] or something oh yeah you can't
say the word [ __ ] normal but this guy was
a gay guy but in 1980 he was a [ __ ] see
that's the difference now he's a gay
that's the evolution of the [ __ ]
so for you to say that [ __ ] where's walt
dad
he's right here he's right let me talk
to that servant well say hello to joey
his people he's yeah he does so he did a
couple questions for you specifically
it's not about the question
joey how are
what's happening happy new year my
brother
to you too man are you still that are
you still six foot six three hundred
pounds six foot nine six foot [ __ ]
nine the house
six five about 285 now how you doing
walking different places how are you
feeling this these days
i'm feeling good man i'm feeling good
about this how was that part of your
life just a [ __ ] nightmare huh
well you know
it was bumpy road but i enjoyed every
bump
you know i can't say uh
i didn't do it i did we had fun landed
on my ass stuff that's all that's it
that's the problem you landed and you
got right back the [ __ ] up you have a
question for walter
i just this is lisa ayat he's the
co-host here hi walter okay it was just
crazy i was i was watching it again
today and they just
they uh described it as like a ball of
adrenaline just like crashing through
like that's that's who i want to be i'm
i'm a short jewish kid who never did
anything and just like just i would love
to be the muscle person that's so cool
just like to know that you're there to
like kick ass
well that's what we did i mean we did do
our jobs
you know we we protected people we
protected the public it was the
extracurricular activities that the
police department didn't appreciate
well it was crazy how you said that like
the police department trained you for
those robberies like you you used the
formation that they trust that they
touch this for the robberies exactly
that's [ __ ] up it's crazy how you said
a word that
uh when i got locked up i worked in the
kitchen and there was a black kid his
name was echi and he would always come
in every day and go freeze
and everybody will actually go what the
[ __ ] and she cut this [ __ ] out
and when you said it it took me back the
[ __ ] ecchi
saying freeze or whatever but uh
i uh you know it was
watching it
you were there it took me there
you know i'm a fan of mike's i'm a fan
of yours uh
you turned your life around and here you
are to tell your story man
and if you really think about that
that's the american way you know
a lot of people it doesn't say in the
film but a lot a lot of people don't
realize i went to prison twice
oh you did get locked up also
i went twice
i went in 89 and again in 92
for the same crimes
no i got arrested in 88 for for
uh knocking off of modago
according to internal affairs
but it was just like what we said it was
a front and we were picking up money
and uh it just went through the system
that's all it did
and then the second one in 92 you came
back and you weren't a cop now obviously
no no i wasn't the cop when i come out i
come out in january 92 and then four
months later uh you know these guys got
locked up and i got sucked in right
along with them only because uh
i knew him
and uh you know
you know it was actually kenny you know
he asked me today one of these days that
i got out of when i got out of jail you
still there i'm gonna go to jail uh he
asked me he says can you deal
you know and i turned him down and you
know i started trying to lead a
straight life and i did
but you know just got caught up in uh
in a whirlwind
in the whirlwind the only after michael
c is and anybody that was attached to
him
in any way shape or form
and uh that's that that's how i ended up
in jail the second time too
but michael's like my brother you know
he took me in my first bit
you know when i got arrested everybody
turned their back on me including family
and you know michael took me in
you know kept an eye on me for a year
before and he drove me to jail
so you know hey
so it's a great outlet you got a story
and a half walter i'm happy you survived
through this i'm happy you got a second
chance we learned the lesson and that's
it you move forward man
enjoy your little vacation
and hopefully i'll meet you guys in new
york in february or
uh mike's gonna come on we're gonna do
the
we're gonna show the 75 in the office in
the studio here we could talk about it
whatever you're welcome
i'll keep you guys posted and that's it
my brother
sounds good man let me talk to mike real
quick and just give him one last yeah if
he's not busy there appreciate the reach
out be good thank you brother
hi joey mike so i'm telling these guys
you're going to come back want to come
in studio we're going to play the movie
we'll sit here for a while talk about it
what you're really going through
because a lot of times you watch stuff
like that and you leave out certain
things
oh yeah you know i wanted to leave this
in so make some notes and we'll chit
chat about that and that's it man i got
nothing but love and respect for you uh
you did what you did you told your story
you did your time listen uh to make some
eggs you're gonna you know to make an
army you're gonna have to break some
eggs i'm sure
people got hurt along the way but
they were in the game also
uh yeah yeah sometimes yeah there's no
one there's some victims here thank god
you know of course they didn't say i had
people murdered and [ __ ] which isn't
true but you know just i want you before
you we shut down i don't know if it's
going out live or not but the
mikedown.com or the mike doubt on
twitter and instagram i wish people just
give me a shout out i try to get back to
everybody that sends me a private
message
and also
john cardillo
show on i heart radio is what we're down
here for that's john clay he's a little
nra nut job right he's a conservative
conservative psycho but he's
entertaining and you know what this is
all about a little bit of entertainment
in my life still so it's john cardillo
at iheart and the mikedow.com or them
like down on twitter and instagram i'd
appreciate it if you can shout that out
hello i try to get back to everybody
okay nowhere amen listen like i said you
got number love for me here and we'll
talk we'll have you in studio
i love his backyard
and uh my feet say hello love you man
stay black i love you thanks for
everything thank you
little tony bennett
[Music]
let me give some shout outs to my main
man david christensen
always talking back and forth me buffalo
magic
i love you guys
valdemar richter mark thomas rob bradley
heidi geldis young down in arizona
holding it down
edwards automotive
and space monkey sean
i love you [ __ ] remember the uh
savage dad tour
starts in charlotte january 28th the
following week in st louis
at uh
whatever the [ __ ]
helium.com but go to joeydiaz.net for
t-shirts and for your tour dates
he uh refixed the webpage we're gonna
start doing the blog on there pretty
soon i think the podcast are up on there
he had the last podcast up so that's
great so the web page is looking up go
to joeydears.net
and see what else is cracker lacking
yeah it's it's listen man
everybody has a
uh a system and
a couple years ago i was on a tour with
a comic who was very nice we got into
the conversation about a dirty cop and
this guy lost his mind
he couldn't believe it and i get it i
had a lot you know as an american you
have a lot of respect for cops
and sometimes but this was a different
time and this was a different era and
the only way you could [ __ ] really
judge it is if you were in there and i
knew those neighborhoods i knew those
[ __ ] neighbors they were i wouldn't
go there really go there for drugs [ __ ]
no [ __ ] no even that that washington
heights in the 80s got scary they killed
the cop with a bucket of spackle they
were throwing spackle from the roofs at
the cops those these [ __ ] were
running you know this was street game
and sometimes you know you look at your
paycheck and you're getting 600 a week
but that's what you signed up for so a
dirty cop is a dirty cop i just happen
to like this guy because these are the
guys i grew up with number one number
two
like i said to you guys i watched this
show and it really [ __ ] up my insides
for a few days because my wife said to
me in new york how did you leave this
place this is you from your head to your
toes what you're doing now is like a
sham of who you are
like
you're a [ __ ] city guy
and people understand it was a big
sacrifice for me to leave it was a
[ __ ] huge sacrifice for me i love new
york city i love the action i love the
adrenaline i love all that [ __ ]
but
part of me knew i wouldn't survive
and i didn't want to die
not like that on the [ __ ] streets not
like that man no and then when i went to
colorado i was i was telling timmy
holloway this morning i was [ __ ]
crazy when i went to colorado when i
went to colorado 85 i was like joe rogan
said it was like putting a kid in a
candy store
i did what the [ __ ] i sold the
membership to the
mob you understand me did you understand
how [ __ ] crazy i was when i got
divorced
in 91 i went back into street mode i
started selling valiums and i started
hustling jack i started selling neon
door-to-door and i just started [ __ ]
hustling and one thing led to another
and you know next thing i'm saying i
always knew that i could go back to
selling something if i got in a bind
those first couple of years here i would
sell something from time to time
i was always putting a move together if
rent wasn't made by the 25th and i had
six days to go that means you got to
sell an eight ball or two you got to
come up with you know four or five
hundred dollars something's got to be
done so i would do it because i always
knew i could go back to it and number
two i was [ __ ] good at it it's what i
know lee it's what i know this comedy
thing was something i hid under and it
hit because i happened to tell these
[ __ ] stories and [ __ ] like that it's
scary it scares the [ __ ] out of me
it's crazy how different people can grow
up like i'm one of the people i watch
that documentary
my only experience with cops
until maybe like high school was officer
rocky he was the dare
cop and he came in and like with like a
stuffed animal
and like
to think about cop is going and
and giving a police escort to the head
of a of a mob
is
blowing just i know what happens now
like now but if i had watched this at
like
well i think corruption is down now i
think corruption still exists
it's just a little down now because you
have more eyeballs you have more film
you have more camera you have more and
still cops are shooting people
you know cops are shooting people more
than [ __ ] ever
but
i mean maybe because i can't steal
me i mean maybe
maybe because they they they were making
all their money from all that i don't
[ __ ] know but it's just uh
listen man you're paid to protect the
public and it turns into something else
and i get it and sometimes life turns
into something
sometimes you come to me and go joey i'm
a good looking girl i'm 23. i got a
great body i got a boyfriend who's a
loser every time i take my shirt off
guys go crazy why shouldn't i go strip
and i'm gonna go strip for six months my
friend said i can make five thousand a
week i don't have to [ __ ] nobody you go
up there you're stripping also in one
day somebody gives you a taste of coke
and you start doing coke and even though
you're doing the classes now you meet
some guy and all of a sudden what you
thought was you had a lid on
you don't have a lid on and i'm just
using a stripper i'm not it could be
anybody it could be a construction
worker it could be anything you just get
caught up in things that's why i always
tell people to think about what they're
doing before they go down there or think
because you never know people [ __ ]
get caught up
and to me i mean
i'm gonna give him the benefit of the
doubt that he was being honest but it
sounded in the documentary like he
liked being a cop and like he was he was
proud of it like when he when they asked
how long were you cop he knew to like
the month
and just stuff like it just seemed like
he was
sometimes life gets out of
sometimes life you just lose hold on it
i know people listen to this podcast
happy is going one way half years of
going the other way
but the bottom line is sometimes you
lose focus or something you wanted to be
in the military right you almost signed
up for the marina which one
something
like what if you had done that then this
could have been the same
path kinda
i i wanted to please my mom my mom
always said you have to join the
military when you get older for a few
years and stuff and
i didn't know what i was gonna do like i
said i had no idea it's not like i grew
up going i'm gonna be a [ __ ] fireman
or
you know i didn't know i didn't [ __ ]
know but once i started doing drugs and
she was gone i had no family and i had
nothing to you know in a way to live for
in a way that's why i became what i did
and that's why i took the chances i did
you know i took the chances i did
because
i really had nobody at home
nobody to please nobody to make proud
nobody do nothing like that and when you
don't have that
you know [ __ ] it i used to tell my
friends listen i'm gonna rob this with
you but i don't want you going in let me
do this
if i get busted you i know your mom i
don't want your mom mad at me [ __ ] like
that
you know
right
and
the other guy in the in the documentary
kenny
in some way i related to him a lot and
how
how he just got caught up in it and the
crit and it sounded kind of like you he
said the only reason he was a cop was
because that test was before the
firefighter test you don't know you
don't know you grew up in some of those
areas you don't really don't know some
kids are blessed
they know exactly what they want to do
with their 16 they want to be a pilot
they already have a path
others don't know what they want to do
to their [ __ ] 30.
and that's just the way it [ __ ]
happens you know
uh i mean it's the
it's the elephant in the room so i gotta
talk about it you know i was talking
about how i never joined nothing
i was never really a part of nothing lee
you know i was a [ __ ] criminal and
when i moved back to colorado in 93 and
i did that stupid thing in new jersey
and i made some money i went with the
intention of becoming a comic i went
back to colorado with two intentions
first to become a dad
and then to become a comic
okay that's that was the plan when you
went back after being in new york new
york this is 93 november of 93 i go back
to colorado
and i uh work at it and i'm trying to be
a dad and i'm trying to do the best i
can but i'm getting into arguments with
this chick and i'm getting hot
with my ex-wife i'm getting hotter and
hotter and all of a sudden
through all this
who i was was coming out i was getting
hotter and hotter and i
when it comes to that i don't know the
diplomacy side i don't know anything of
that side i just know the street side of
things
i know the street side of things and you
can't disrespect me and i can't
disrespect you this can't keep going up
and i got out of the control and
whatever
and i got hotter and hotter and uh
like i said i was a criminal then i
would rob anything in those days
especially
after i got out of prison and after i
got separated
i was very careful in my steps
i was very careful what i did
were you not careful before
i was always careful but i didn't pay
attention i paid attention a lot more
i paid attention to what i was selling
what i was who i was with the things i
was doing
i wanted to keep things under a certain
radar so if i did have to go back to
jail you're following me
and i was in my in my heart i just
wanted to get out of whatever i was
doing and just be a comedian but it
didn't work that way
it didn't work that way you had to work
hard
you know and i would go out at night and
some months man i made it i paid my rent
and i could pay my car payment i could
pay a little child support or whatever
and some months i didn't in the months i
didn't i sold pills or i sold coke or
you know i robbed some whatever the [ __ ]
i could do late you know
then i got into comedy
and i like i said i never belonged
anything i was lost
and from the minute i got the [ __ ]
comedy people come up to me and say hey
man is mitzi sure seeing you yet
when she sees you you're gonna be at the
[ __ ] store
and all of a sudden i get made a regular
at the [ __ ] store
and one thing leads to another and i
gotta tell you something man i did some
[ __ ] up things at the store like i
would steal phones like cell phones
people would do like help lost and found
and put them in lost and i would take
three phones and take them with crenshaw
and sell them to this black bank robber
i know
that had uh he used to hang out with
eddie griffin at the comedy store and
they were criminals they also got they
got arrested for robbing a bank in l.a i
know we don't have time for that story
right now but we're going to put a pin
in that yeah which one the [ __ ]
background is
from crenshaw they used to hang out at
the store with eddie griffin
and i became they were from st louis
they in fact they did a long stretch for
bank robbery here in l.a one of them got
shot right here in l.a that's why i
don't see them i never saw those guys
again this is 99 2000.
but as i had a hard time there in the
beginning some guy said i was doing it
he was jewish and he said i was doing
one of his jokes and i kind of pushed
him and he fell down i never really had
a problem after that i had an argument
with don barris
i had an argument with this kid that uh
broke the microphone one night i told
him don't touch the microphone because
you're gonna break the microphone and
nobody else gonna be able to go up what
do you think the [ __ ] kid did he
broke the microphone so me him and this
other kid went to war for a few months
but it was things that happened with
personalities
it wasn't me trying to be a scumbag to
other comedians
when i before i got into comedy i read
that book by [ __ ] my favorite jewish
comic well there was lenny bruce
and there's one book and he spoke about
the camaraderie of comics and i had
always believed in the camaraderie of
comics i wasn't a criminal no more you
know guys i'm i'm good at some things
but i'm very naive at the others you
know
uh
you know there's treachery in in the
regular business world there's treachery
at a at a
fortune 500 company that's always
chumbly trying to stab somebody in the
back
but i so naively i didn't really believe
that happened in comedy
until i got to the store
why did you think it was because it's
just it was positive like why would it
yeah it was an art it was an art you
know it was just something that i didn't
really have to [ __ ] with lee
you know i didn't know i had to [ __ ]
with lee to do this so when i got to the
store people tried to [ __ ] me a little
bit and i bounced back and then i just
did my spots and then i got into some
beeps and and the word got out that i
stuck up for myself
and i really didn't give a [ __ ] so
people left me to [ __ ] alone okay and
and also
i'm in there and this kid comes in and
he's really cool and we used to talk all
the time john caporillo we talked about
this or that and blah blah blah blah
blah blah
and he was a funny kid and he would go
on stage and everybody giggled and i
used to giggle with [ __ ] uh
duncan me and duncan had him believing
that if he wanted spots he had to pay 15
a spot this is how he did at the comedy
store and he was so naive he was just a
sweet kid but one day he starts getting
success and he starts
duncan quits after they did the the
comedy store show on tnt remember years
ago tbs did the the paulie shore and all
that i heard about it duncan quit duncan
said [ __ ] you i'm not being no show i'm
not being no show with paulie shaw so
duncan quit so they made the phone guy
the [ __ ]
talent coordinator which wasn't a good
move on mitzi but she didn't have time
to look around plus the kid took the job
for [ __ ] peanuts
but after about two or three years the
kid's
job went through his [ __ ] head
and here's his caparoulo kid [ __ ]
with tommy you know and they they like
each other and whatever means and
in 2006 i was [ __ ] knee-deep an
addiction dog i would basically go to
the store to buy blow
i would do my spot and make a u-turn and
go to either el compadre or to the
martel cartel and buy blow and go home
and i could see that there was something
in the air that was different
you know joe rogan was huge he was
coming off fear factor
he would pack the place every week with
a [ __ ] uh myspace and that day or
whatever the [ __ ] was popular in my
space it was my space and he packed the
place out and i could tell
there wasn't a good feeling towards him
he was doing 40 minutes not on my end i
loved it he would get me and ari to go
up perform and do 15 minutes
you know and he would he would follow us
you know like he would go i want to
follow these two [ __ ] guys because
they make me work you know
and things got started getting heated
and one day i'm sitting on the thing
it's like october
of 2006 i'm deep in addiction guys
i'm about to get surgery on my neck
the fat ball i had on my neck
and i'm sitting out there and also joe
rogan's on tour with
tom segura
charlie murphy and the other kid from
michigan there's a really nice kid john
john heffron and they're doing a tour
i'm sitting out there and [ __ ] comes up
to me copper rule and he goes hey man
when your buddy comes back he's trying
to be cute he goes when your boss or
your buddy comes back he's not going to
be able to do 40 minutes and then tommy
came out he said did you tell him and
they were both giggling i go you know
what both these could go [ __ ] yourselves
and i knew what time it was they went
away giggling too
but i knew what time it was i could see
that something was a bruin you know uh
the night with the paulie short thing
when tnt came to see him they didn't
make rogan go up on stage and then there
was an argument between paulie and this
other manager and joe rogan and i turned
my back because i thought rogan was
going to knock him out i wanted if i had
to take a lie detective test i wanted to
pass it were you looking no did you hear
the smacks [ __ ] no but brogan didn't
smack those guys rogan is smart and he
walked away and that was the end of the
conversation i knew it had something to
do with just [ __ ] people the way they
get comics are [ __ ] little cut
sometimes
so
one day i got a call from [ __ ] tommy
like january before i do the surgery and
on my neck and he's telling me how
carlos came in there and bumped john and
that's not right and i tell him i said
listen man the last i checked carlos on
tv he gets every right well you're wrong
you're wrong caparulo's funny cap is a
funny guy but he ain't funny in [ __ ]
carlos bro and nobody knows who the [ __ ]
he is so knock it the [ __ ] off with that
[ __ ] well i wanted you to tell joe what
they were trying me to do was to get joe
riled up eventually he got joe riled up
on his own and whatever went down with
carlos happened i was not daylighting
that night i was recovering from my next
uh the surgery and once i saw that fat
ball that came out of my neck it was the
people talking [ __ ] behind my back i
could see that [ __ ] comedy store so i
said [ __ ] it i'm not going in there no
more with those [ __ ] espinitos
mallows i just made up my mind two
months before like that december i'm
like i'm not going in there no more
because i know i'm gonna end up knocking
somebody to [ __ ] out number one you
think you would have hit somebody
jesus i was close so i said [ __ ] it and
then the jeff valdez thing went down
and i went back in there one more time
and that proved it i went off on him a
fight the new the la times wrote a story
about it that i [ __ ] called the guy
out for being a creep another [ __ ]
creepy producer jeff valdez
so i admit that really pushed me over
like i hadn't been there nine months if
i had any thoughts of being in there
they were done that night and i just
didn't come back i wasn't banned or none
i walked out on my own two feet like a
gentleman
but the whole time i'm hearing these
[ __ ] ramblings about this [ __ ] copper
rulo
i'm hearing these [ __ ] little
ramblings how he's telling people they
can't go up in front this went on for
years you know
rogan was doing that friday when they
threw joe rogan out the comments was
supposed to do a walk
but mitchy sure said if somebody walked
out they wouldn't get spots no more so
they bailed so right there my
camaraderie belief in comedy went out
the [ __ ] window right there and i
told joe a thousand times don't even
talk to those punk ass [ __ ] no more
but joe's a nice guy me i see him now i
say hello but i know what they're about
you can't take these [ __ ] into war
because they're going to fold
so go ahead
i hate to say are you worried that
something that might happen with what
oh sure now i really don't care because
that's the biggest i learned that lesson
earlier yeah i really don't people
people will go like route like rally you
up and then when it's time they all walk
away if you listen to the carlos mencia
tape they're in the back jumping yelling
screaming once it was time to bail up
nobody did [ __ ] dick so but anyway
that's a complete different story this
is going on over the years i'm hearing
this [ __ ] i'm hearing that he's saying
i'm not funny that tommy's saying i'm
not funny that mitch i was mitzi's
favorite blah blah blah blah blah blah
so i didn't say it and then one day i
stopped doing blow and i started
thinking about it
so like in 2013 or something i was doing
an interview and i said it i said
capriles a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and his buddy tommy i wasn't going back
up that didn't give a [ __ ] and what are
they gonna do come get me at my house is
that what you think they're going to
[ __ ] do they don't have the ball
anybody who goes to a talent coordinator
and tells them that you can't put
somebody on before me
or after me then he started complaining
about bobby lee going on after him
you know why
because he was too funny he wanted to be
the star of the whole [ __ ] night
he wanted people to leave at 11 and go
wow that caparoulos something else so he
wouldn't let bobby lee go up then he
started on [ __ ] build crystal ear
and then you know when when adam came
back the town coordinator from the store
came back he had to call a bunch of
other comedians to say come back hannah
barbara's al madrigal he called a bunch
of comedians and yeah some of them had
problems with tommy but some of them had
problems because capra really didn't
like him there if caberullo felt
threatened by them he's that much of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he felt threatened by that
and that's not what a comic does a comic
doesn't take money out of somebody
else's pocket okay i'm very hurt and two
things that happened in my career once i
didn't book the sopranos because steve
sharippur went and talked about me to
the producers i didn't like that i
didn't get the job he took money out of
my [ __ ] pocket somewhere along the
line you have to pay for that that's
karma when you take money out of
somebody's pocket just like stealing
you're stealing it's the same [ __ ]
principle i i feel i never give a bad
review to anybody like an uber driver
like i i i feel bad
and i've heard of people being like i
don't want to follow somebody he's too
funny i've never heard of someone saying
i don't want someone to follow me there
that's what he was doing so and listen
when somebody says they don't want you
following me
that means you want to be the funniest
[ __ ] guy around you don't want to be
[ __ ] threatened
so people left people like you know what
like a lot of people went down there and
capped rulo probably i don't want him
down here and sure enough time he
believed him and trust me i've heard
those stories too of people going down
there and being funny after him
and never getting a spot ever again like
until late night you know just a
thousand shitty thing and tommy did a
thousand [ __ ] he did not only that but
he robbed the [ __ ] joint he got
caught with his hand the cookie jar
behind the register here's the kid with
a trust fund
that was robin you understand me so
listen both of them suck dick both of
them are two dick sucking [ __ ]
so rogan goes on this i go on rogan's
podcast christmas eve
and i say the truth rogan's up there
being a nice guy saying oh well the
[ __ ] guy uh you know the comedy store
the computers uh why cool people go no
no cool people go down there because
tommy and that [ __ ] caparoola don't go
down there no more so a couple weeks ago
what's the fat dude from [ __ ] the
goldbergs oh jeff jeff garland goes down
and bumps caparoola that's why he didn't
see him for a long time
that's why he hadn't been down it cuz he
was pissed about that he was pissed
about me and joe being back down there
he was pissed about magic he was pissed
about the lineups bro he's pissed about
the heart of the lineups this is a comic
that's just at home
you know and that's all he's [ __ ]
doing and have like having the lineup
been great the lineups are sensational
and he's not on him he's not on him
because he ain't around
this [ __ ] smoke this [ __ ] fire
guys i'm not making this [ __ ] [ __ ] up
this is not slander this is a human
being telling you what the [ __ ] happened
ari went up to him the other night and
was like you this is what you did he's
still not coming to it do you understand
what claiming responsibility is if he
would have just claimed responsibility
this would have been over i don't even
give off i don't give a [ __ ] if that
little miserable [ __ ] [ __ ] gets hit by
a [ __ ] car i don't give a [ __ ] it
don't matter to me all i wanted him to
do is to know what he did well he starts
up with me on twitter the other day and
i said some [ __ ] i went overboard but i
had to give it to him listen art of war
sun tzu if the [ __ ] guy you're going
up against is about
[ __ ] up tolerance agitate this
[ __ ] no end what agitates a
[ __ ] more roberto duran you know
how he won the fight against sugar ray
land the first time
he walked up to him in montreal and he
said i'm gonna [ __ ] your wife up the
[ __ ] ass it got into [ __ ] sugar
ray's head so much that he lost the
first fight put it on put it on it's a
true story about that don't put it on
here put it on when you get home true
story in montreal first time roberto
duran fought [ __ ] sugar ray leonard
sugar ray nice guy of the year walking
down the street with his family
and he sees where birdie goes let me
introduce roberto to my wife roberto
shakes his hand and goes i'm gonna [ __ ]
your wife up the ass it threw him off
for two weeks and lost the [ __ ] fight
lost the fight
lost the [ __ ] fight because you lose
the fight in your head first
this isn't a fight but i i gain nothing
by smacking this [ __ ] punk he's a
punk i wouldn't dirty my hands i never
intended to i just wanted him to know
what to [ __ ] apologize and if you're
not gonna apologize then don't come to
the comedy store no more
don't come to the comedy store because
now i arouse this
people know this you know many people
[ __ ] call me and not animals nice
white people call me you know how many
open mics hit me up and said thank you
that that guy's a [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] to us
when he walks in the building that
dude's a [ __ ] to everybody
so when ari's talking to him yesterday
he's still not claiming responsibility
he don't do nothing this kid he don't do
nothing
why have him around
so i had to say what i had to say i
wasn't lying if you've watched the
twitter feed he never accused me of
lying he didn't nothing he called me
names i'm grandpa that i'm old that i
wasn't funny that i was hanging on his
jock when he got a deal what deal that
was his [ __ ] heyday that was all he's
ever done [ __ ] i've done [ __ ] movies
with savages you know for all the [ __ ]
he did he nobody follows him on twitter
he said i was irrelevant and not funny
this kid's a [ __ ] punk this kid's a
[ __ ] punk and he'll always [ __ ] be
a punk a comic and then he started
putting at the comedy store as a comedy
uh what is that artist calling an artist
comedy well then you should have acted
like one you should have acted like one
you never did you think people are
coming after you now and saying these
things to you because they feel bad for
you
i'm not bullying this kid i got no
reasonable i don't give a [ __ ] if this
[ __ ] maggot falls off a [ __ ]
bridge tonight and gets hit by a truck
and then the [ __ ] lions eat them to
death i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] you know i don't give a [ __ ] but
the point is how he didn't claim
responsibility
everything was everybody else's and now
some of the comics have been happy from
what i did but none of them besides are
we gonna go up to him and go hey dog you
[ __ ] up well you know what sad this
might be it might be bullying in today's
culture like in in your world it's just
telling the truth but now you can't even
you can't even say the truth even i'm
i'm not saying you're wrong no no no no
no i know and i know some people will
upset by my comments i don't really give
a [ __ ] if they were upset i really don't
i really don't i'm too old to get
worried about what [ __ ] people think
anymore and if you're young don't [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] you did it it's done
this is how i feel in my heart i'm not
saying i'm gonna smack the guy i don't
the dog i got a beautiful wife and a
beautiful family i have a great time
with you guys and i have a great support
group with you guys i just wanted people
to know you know what man aren't you
sick and tired of getting conned
you liked bill cosby remember how you
like bill cosby remember how you liked
jared he was sweet
you know i'm sick and tired of you
[ __ ] people somebody didn't raise you
right there you can't judge character
right off the bat maybe i am a [ __ ] up
guy but i'll tell you what call me with
a problem i'm the first [ __ ] guy
there it's we live in a different time
you don't see me with i went to the park
there there with my daughter i seen a
father
in 50 degree weather 60 degree weather
with a scarf and a cashmere sweater and
flip-flops on and a hat like sinatra
these people have no [ __ ] soul you
know everybody talks about isis is
killing our country you know who's
killing our country these [ __ ]
gentiles and their home base is right
here in l.a see the home base of these
little [ __ ] politically correct
[ __ ] fake because that's all you are
when you're telling me you're
politically correct you're telling me
you for your faith because if you're a
woman if you've ever had a [ __ ] black
dick in your hand or a [ __ ] dick in
your hand or if you're a man and you
have had a woman bent over and you're
eating her [ __ ] you cannot be
politically correct
you cannot lie
these people you see all the time these
people you see at these when my wife and
daughter go to church on a big white
church where everybody go
i bet half those [ __ ] people [ __ ]
their grandkids they do a bunch of
shitty [ __ ]
but they have they go to church and
they're politically correct and they
like saturday night live and did you
hear the joke the black chubby kid said
[ __ ] you that show hasn't been funny in
[ __ ] 30 years if somebody comes up to
you and says they watch saying that live
that's the first judge of character i
don't want to be around this [ __ ] guy
you know what did john lennon say
if you say the truth
you're only going to have two friends or
something like that i'd rather just have
two friends anymore i'd rather have two
people listen to this [ __ ] podcast
than these people that wear hats and
everything is for you know it's like
what you said you seen on new year's eve
people who were just there to go see
bill bird just and he was having a heart
he was like kind of getting mad at the
audience because i went to the early
show which i i normally don't go to
because sometimes the the crowds are a
little tighter but i wanted to get home
and it was just the people in in the
crowd were all wearing like
crazy like it was it was like hipster
center like downtown is
all hipster it's it's turned into what
this season of south park is so like
they make fun of like whole foods going
in in the middle of downtown there's a
brand new whole foods and it's just it
was just
the people that i saw down there were
just crazy and then i had the best
just to go off a little bit
you see all these people going out and
partying i had the best time of new
year's i was home at 10 and i was i was
on the couch by like 10 30 we eating
burgers that we made it's so much better
it's so much better than what
i used to feel remember when we started
this podcast and i used to say i used to
feel like i missed out on i didn't miss
out on [ __ ] not nothing nothing yeah i
told you that bro when i was a kid i
stopped going out at night and people
were like oh my god i'm like i'm not
missing nothing
it's it's and it's a sacrifice but once
you realize nothing happened
nothing
anything
and it i did i didn't make
a mistake we i uh
i didn't want to take an edible but i
wanted to get high so i was ha i smoked
was smoking a joint and two cops rolled
by so and i just threw the joint and i
was like [ __ ]
so i didn't i didn't i was wondering
what you would do like if you were
smoking out how do you smoke outside
like that keep your eyes open the cop
should never be on you what if a cop
comes by he'll never do because i'm
facing everything and if you see a cop
it gives you time to put the joint down
and stand there with an e-cigarette in
your hand
wait but do you throw the drone away no
you put it next to your foot and step on
the [ __ ] red spot and just step away
five feet from it oh two feet and just
keep opening your feet and get make
believe you're on the phone i got a
paranoid i just tossed then we just ran
away no no you first thought he should
how far from you was he was in the car
there was no way he even said oh oh
you're such a [ __ ] amateur
yeah and there's no way in the car bro i
didn't want to get arrested on new
year's eve keep it low we're not going
to arrest you for a joint you're a nice
kid they're going to look up your name
yeah you got a license don't you yeah
then why they're going to arrest you
can you smoke on the street i'll smoke
wherever the [ __ ] i smoked on the street
before the [ __ ] license what do i
give a [ __ ] oh it's got to be prepared
you got to sit there and look around you
got to have another cigarette in your
hand just in case or an e-cigarette
go buy an e-cigarette and just have it
in your hand and you hang out and beat
the people
and if you see the cop you don't do this
you don't do nothing it just opens
just release your arm stays the same you
don't even move you just go
pop and your heel goes over you take
care of the cherry and you put your foot
that if that
and you stand there what are you doing
here i'm on the phone my sister keep
[ __ ] going [ __ ] and they'll
drive away
that's how scared i am of the cops oh my
god you're [ __ ] scared you pay taxes
you're a nice [ __ ] kid you don't do
nothing to bother nobody listen
everybody's making resolutions
everybody's doing this
everybody's doing that uh especially for
meals and food and what you're gonna eat
you want a [ __ ] great deal
do you know what is just tremendous
every time i've made them at home listen
i've only cooked this
blue apron at home maybe seven times i'm
not gonna lie to you all the meals that
i've had at the house but i ordered good
[ __ ] i ordered good [ __ ] i'm not gonna
order something my couscous i don't
[ __ ] like those goods
so you can admit it the last thing
anybody wants to do after work is wait
online at a grocery store and then
schlep home and then cook a [ __ ]
complicated meal it's expensive and
unhealthy takeout is hardly any better
that's where this new service blue apron
comes in blue apron delivers farm fresh
ingredients and step by step recipes to
your home allowing you right i'm talking
to you [ __ ] to create a healthy
handcrafted meal at home without going
to the grocery store for less than ten
bucks a day ten dollars per meal bloiper
sends you fresh ingredients perfectly
proportioned making cooking healthy
meals really easy and fun no trips to
the grocery store no waste unused
ingredients oh i forgot this plus you'll
learn to cook with specialty ingredients
that are normally hard to find blue
apron is also perfect for date night you
meet a chick at a bar listen you want to
come over and lick my nuts i'll cook for
you absolutely it's perfect for date
night cooking with friends and they even
offer family plans for like four people
that with kid-friendly ingredients let's
say your kids are half a momo he can't
eat peanuts we'll figure out a way so
the whole family can eat well and have
fun and prepare meals together each meal
is 500 to 700 calories per serving and
it's tasty as hell you won't even know
all right shipping is flexible and free
and the menus are always new like this
week you got juicy lucy burgers you got
three cheese calzones and the family
package has shrimp scampi with
fettuccine and lemon ricotta and
brussels sprout pizza okay
that's the kind of stuff they have so
they work around your schedule and
dietary preferences and with blue aprons
experts source only the best seasonal
ingredients for incredible meals like
the ones i just spoke about you'll cook
incredible meals and be blown away by
the quality and the freshness
blue apron is a better way to cook
especially if you're trying to save some
money and trying to cut down on calories
check out this week's menu and get your
first two meals for free by going to
blueapron.com
joey again two meals for free check out
the menu by going to blueapron.com
joey no treat my treat really the first
two meals are on me when you go to
blueapron.com
slash joey that's joey
all right they're going to send all
fresh ingredients to your little casa
and everything's going to be beautiful i
know a lot of you as well i would kill
for that trim
i'm done this is not a bad deal guys oh
my god give it a shot go to
blueapron.com give it a shot just go to
the menu and see what they got even if
you just start with doing two meals a
week two meals you hate cooking or two
trust me it's not a bad deal another
thing wine everybody wants to get drunk
everybody wants to know why nobody knows
wine nobody really knows it you know you
get these people that know stuff and you
know how long you got to study for that
i ain't got that time you got that type
of time you know it's going to take a
club w okay
club w
listen club w is the new
the new directly from the grape to the
glass wine revolution they're sweeping
the nation they work directly with
vineyards to cut out the middleman which
saves you money you know for nine
thousand years since jesus is walking
around but he's been drinking wine
that's also how long people been
confused about what type of wine to
drink do i drink red with chicken
what kind of wine do i get am i getting
ripped off you know you see the report
on 60 minutes no sending america italian
products over here and they're fake you
know all these things you don't know so
for many of us the shopping cart really
causes the real headache you got too
many car too many choices and too many
things to learn and it's expensive with
no guarantee you're gonna like what you
buy all right so you ever buy a bottle
of wine you bring it to somebody's house
they taste it they look like you fought
it you know you spent 13 18
you know you don't need this aggravation
in your life well do this i joined a new
wine club called club w they changed the
game it's easy you go to clubw.com and
you answer six questions that's it six
questions the algorithm creates a
palette profile just for you you like
orangey ones that are sweet blah blah
blah you eat caps brains whatever it is
they'll hook you up then they'll send
the wine directly to your door perfectly
customized to match your taste
excuse me it comes really quick and it's
packed and it comes in like two days
beautiful it's beautiful it comes right
to your door there's nothing broken none
of that they package it beautifully so
with club w you get premium one
customized your taste at a third of what
you pay at the store they even have a no
risk 100 money back guarantee that
you'll love when they send you all right
right now go to club w they're offering
my listeners 50 off your first order
when you go to club w dot com slash joey
again club w dot com slash joey stop
wasting time stop messing around at
retail stores and start drinking wine
you know you're going to love go to club
w joey and get 50 off your first order
that's right club w
joey also my main men over at on it i
seen aubrey the other day was on the
rogan podcast today listen those guys
are always doing something fantastic i
don't even look at their web page today
because i usually look to see what i can
order and torment them
i'm living off the alpha brain i listen
i got sick one time last year it's not
bad with shune tech immune i fly every
weekend guys you have a fly you come
back with a headache or a sore throat
two immunes before i get on the plane
and i'm bad i'm brand new let's say you
go to a bar you're like sucking dick
drinking one other people's glasses
that's where that immune works for you
shroom tech immune stream tech sport
they have so many great quality [ __ ]
ingredients and supplements you're gonna
go crazy too many for me to name and too
many for me to know what even i'm
[ __ ] talking about so do me a favor
let's cut this [ __ ] go right now you got
new resolutions you want to get in shape
go to honor.com look at the great
selection of supplements that they have
if you find something you like what
you're going to like it gets delivered
right to your house i'll tell you what
i'm going to do i'm going to save you 10
off your first order right now go to
honor.com
east covered church church c-h-u-r-c-h
and get 10 off your first order
everybody's been hitting me up they love
the shroom tech they love the the hemp
force protein the chocolate shake they
love this stuff guys the tea
testosterone booster the coconut oil for
the coffees and stuff they love anything
from on it go to honor.com right now and
press in and get 10 off your first order
delivered to your house i want to thank
blue apron i want to thank annette and i
want to thank club w for sponsoring from
food to wine to supplements i'm always
here for you guys i want to thank mike
dodd again i'll let you guys know what
we're doing it's going to be like a
three-day 7-5 podcast we're just going
to break this [ __ ] thing down see
what the guy felt whatever if you don't
like it don't [ __ ] watch all right
you know i love you [ __ ] always
we'll be back wednesday
or thursday i don't [ __ ] know we'll
be back we're moving offices but we're
going to continue on with the podcast so
don't worry about none i love you
[ __ ] with all my heart lisa
yeah take it away [ __ ] don't
forget charlotte january 28th st louis
helium comedy club february 4th through
the 7th
vegas february 19th for my birthday for
some of you [ __ ] that don't
know
happy birthday don't bother me will you
the show is brought to you by blue apron
blue princess gourmet recipes and all
the fresh ingredients you need to make
them right to your door
our listeners get their first two meals
for free when you go to blue apron dot
com slash joey show is also brought to
you by club w club w is the wine club
that changed everything and right now
they're offering our listeners 50 off of
your first order when you go to club
w.com joey and go to onnit.com use
codeword church to get 10 off all the
great optimization products
[Music]